brava a tutti ragazzi benvenute questo
non vi the son of a viggiano ci sono con
pietro su bene dead set anzi benedetti
che una vita che non lo facevo il
livello che facciamo oggi ragazzi l'ho
scaricato da internet secondo me è
talmente difficile che potremmo anche
non riuscirci però importante provarci
abbiamo messo 30 vita e disponibili per
morto bassi non basteranno mai prova
bene vai ma siamo 1.6 chrono sì che
siamo uno contro l'altro veloce veloce
effetto la partenza ma come raccomandato
schifoso merico vieni qua marina e io
sono ancora anch'io sono vivo in
vantaggio non ci sono le gambe che però
potevamo servirmi [__] corrida globale
non valeva il primato così se ci sono
ostacoli cicali primato vai vai vai
esatto non ci credo è stato bravissimo
vai vai pietro e pietro
vai amico ciao ciao ciao poveri aiuto
non sto guardo io no mi ok mica sono
stato bravissimo sono così a prossimo
check point sidebar serata grande ombra
come come si fa qua di santana sbagliato
ho sbagliato sono scemo scemo e due
checkpoint scusa e li parole non farò
mai sono io mi sento di aiuto io sono
fatta se ho fatto già fatta credo ha
preso c'è poi sono fermi videoprova no
no no no non provo niente non trova
assolutamente in via
beh cosa vedo sto saltando tutta livello
aiuta
no che non giovano sto facendo è roba
incredibile simile ha preso certo menta
che ti guarda ti guardo un attimo di
vedere dovere ma non posso passare dai
corvi codici pensare quali arrivato lì
non c'è la testa lancia testa più paura
lancia gg
dai vent'anni per fare sto cavolo di
livello dai vieni che ti tocca solo giro
da tara bene vai o che ti ho aspettato
un'ora e mezza e quindi sono posso fare
questo noi siamo con l'api riad e leva
sulla peer into qua quanti incasinato st
livello ok ayachi botta in faccia forte
sono vivo che è poi concentrata
intensità quale voleva che fenomeno
c'è poi l'ho preso l'ho preso l'ho preso
perfetto ma ci 6 6
[Musica]
io l'ho studiando amico ma dov'è il
finale quali gol prove ci prova ora che
ci provo io l'ho ma tu vada o no no non
è vero
mica sto arrivando infine stiamo
arrivando il finale te lo giuro come un
fatto non lo so mica sto facendo così
incredibile ok
guardalo che arrivò a finale guardano ce
l'ha fatta
c'è un fatto incredibile eccoti risorse
per spettava ancora lì si odia va bene
ne facciamo un'altra c6 questa in coppi
sì però io ti picchio uguale a quello di
prima era figo è non riuscire a farlo
mera figo coop
che bello i cuoricini medie ci sono le
trappole pure di ammonio e fatti perché
dietro c'è una trappola a bordo io sto
andando vai la barca leva o partito da
dio no mica come fare un buco avanti
grazie pietro grazie per farla
ovviamente non so come farei senza di te
che io ai corri puledra torri ed eccoci
qua fermo fermo fermo facebook
c'era una roba qua guarda di venire con
me perché sono un casino dai loro in
vado e faccio i cazzi miei
dai vieni guarda che non possiamo andare
avanti se la storia non so quale il
karma il carlo lo sapevo capitolato non
si può andare avanti uguale lanciando la
testa lì proprio magari difficile va dai
tre ai bebè viveri a fare 92 ganna lo
vedi mai dritto sei tu che m'hai storto
capito
magari non ci posso gara possiamo non
possiamo essere due triple di kosice non
ci posso credere veramente quanti
youtuber ci vogliono per salire su un
ascensore mai fatto come fa se anche ho
capito di non essere chiusa la testa no
no anche sono in piedi come si fa a
prima porta qua del sito
ecco qua si è aperto s'è aperta mettono
dietro che non ci fossi io come segno ha
dovuto far domande
eh sì che ho visto non ha capito che è
successo eccoti vento pietro tentò
grazie a volume è mai banale sono amico
vieni via i miei volevo tardi ci voleva
ma scusa guarda guarda me ora dove sono
mi vedi chimera davanti giro che si può
fare te lo giuro guarda guarda guarda
all'aspetto prendo c'è poi da contrario
ciao non mi toccare questo provo andare
qua sinistra ok e io vado a destra anzi
io devo partita ma ti devo muovere tiro
muovere faccio io mi fermo io allora
dico parti
l'ingegnere poi vorrei di veto di
indicarmi indica vendicami giallo giallo
per il giusto suggello salta ok blu blu
ok no un po un po giallo o blu blu blu
blu blu bianco verde verde o blu
ok allora basta perfetti se cadevi con
quest'altro sarei potuto morire di
crepacuore aspetta che c'è qualcosa qua
cosa faccio comico e mori che ne so
lì partì ace poi intanto nella mia ma ne
valore ma così starò mai ha dato la
zucca vieni vieni ci sono case a 26 al
gameplay vai 21 via ti ho visto cadere
ara lenti ma va bene
no cesso rappresentando la madre di chi
sa che da questo gioco in questo momento
c'è il mio character e quello dai amico
forza allora è difficile ok ma non lo
sapevo che io ti ho aspettato per quale
motivo per quale motivo di aspettato
spiegami ti prego non picchiarmi quando
il rischio che per fondo perché io cioè
tu ad arrivare no premessa difficile mi
chiedevi accontentare scusami ma se
trampolino a sinistra pista rischi prima
parte dell'europa perché devo fare che
devo fare non lo so salta di testa che
ha fatto
abbiamo schiacciato che si possa trovare
costante giuste
questo era giusto bravissimo non usare
ok ok perfetto vai
ecco quelle per te pietro lo vedi ma ora
dito dritto ma perché no al nyse stj
guarda guarda guarda quanto godo guarda
dove dove il prossimo c'è non lo so non
c'è proprio sparito proprio ora che si
abbassa pure quando sono il libro no no
prego bravo sei stato tu mi sei piaciuto
orca vacca che male c'è non ci credo
ora che siamo in coppia doveva arrivarci
insieme pietro la senatrice ma io arrivo
un appena una donna che botta riprese
madonna
ok sono svenuto
devo devi mandare tutto ok vedove dove
lo aspetta esatto esatto
sono morto mi sono fatto ok io so non ho
mai visto che no no no no no se lo
facciamo insieme non vinciamo 2 1 mai
fermo porca vacca vorrei già facciamo a
fare così guarda guarda ti puoi lanciare
direttamente di poi lancia niente mente
costi check point da qua io ho fatto
esatto esatto è stato bellissimo
cioè dei geni ma edizione dei geni del
male o ce l'abbiamo fatta a farla roba
decente nella vita ma vi è piaciuto
bravo mi sei piaciuto signori ci siamo
riusciti io sono uscita finire di tutti
e due lui uno solo però aveva già
qualcosa insomma cioè le scimmie sono
evolute c'è voluto il suo tempo servirà
anche a pietro ragazzi io spero che vi
sia piaciuto come al solito se il video
è piaciuto il suo momento è un bel like
anche la lista c'è quindi una
descrizione city chiede vediamo un pò
seguito da ragazzi devo fare una roba
figlia no però non sono riuscito
beh va beh
[Musica]